To explain how we can actually keep this
from getting out of hand if it doesn't
need to be, we're going to
look at one special operation.
And let me draw
a picture of it first and
then we'll talk about
it more mathematically.
All right, so do you [LAUGH]
do you see what I drew here?
>> A web.
>> [LAUGH] Yeah,
it doesn't look so great, does it?
So this is intended to be a piecewise
linear convex function, so
basically a value function.
And remember that what we end up doing
is over belief space, that's the black
line here, we're going to be taking
the max over all these linear functions.
So we get this upper surface.
>> Wait, I see, you can get rid of
any of the vectors that don't ever
participate in the max
because they don't matter.
>> Yeah, and so that's going to keep
our vector sets potentially from
blowing up if they don't need to.
So in this particular case I drew, what,
one, two, three, four, five vectors.
But only three of them are really
needed to represent the function.
This one's not needed and
this one is not needed.
So we can define a computational
operation, that we call purge,
that takes a bag of vectors and
shrinks it down,
purges out any vectors that
aren't really needed to represent
the upper surface,
the piecewise linear convex function.
>> Wait, how computationally
complicated is it to do that?
>> That's a good question.
>> Thank you.
>> [LAUGH] So
how computationally complicated is it?
>> It's at least linear.
>> It's at least linear, yeah, and so
there's some quick
tests that you can do.
So let's look at this vector first,
this vector number one here.
If you look, what you can see
is that over belief space,
this 01 zone here,
there's another vector,
specifically this one, call it
vector 2 that always dominates it.
It is always the case
that you can do better
by taking vector 2 instead of vector 1.
So if there's a vector that is
dominated by another vector,
you could totally throw it out.
>> But you ought to be able to
figure out by doing something cute,
like multiplying them together or
taking their cosine or
their angle, there's something you ought
to be able to do to figure that out.
>> Actually all you have
to do is check the corners.
>> If it's bigger on both 0 and 1, that
must be bigger the whole way through.
>> Well, in particular,
let's say we have two vectors like this,
with components alpha 1, alpha 2,
alpha 3, and this is this vector.
And the other vector's represented
by alpha 1 prime, alpha 2 prime,
alpha 3 prime.
If it's the case that alpha 1 is
bigger than alpha 1 prime, and
alpha 2 is bigger than alpha 2 prime,
and
alpha 3 is bigger than alpha 3 prime,
then this vector is not needed, right.
No matter what belief
state you stick in,
you're going to get a higher value out
by using this vector than that one.
>> Does it have to be strictly
dominated, or can it just be dominated?
So, if one is greater than or
equal to the other,
you can get rid of the one that
is less than or equal to, right?
>> Yes.
>> All right, that's neat.
>> Yeah, there's some subtleties
to doing this consistently.
In my dissertation,
I talk about how you can use a
lexicographic ordering of the vectors to
make sure that you only keep things that
really are going to be needed someplace.
But that is a subtlety that I don't
think is very important for this.
This dominated check is actually really
easy to do and it's very fast, but
unfortunately, it's not sufficient.
So let's look at this vector,
we'll call it number 3.
This one is better than
each of the other vectors,
at some point along the way, but
the union of the other vector, the union
of these three vectors dominates it.
So showing that is actually
considerably more difficult.
Knowing that 3 doesn't matter,
isn't needed, because over
here it's dominated by this vector, over
here it's dominated by this vector, and
over here it's dominated by that vector.
>> Wait, what you said isn't true.
3 is dominated by the one that first
does the max all the way through.
>> You mean this one, 4?
>> Yeah.
>> Yes, that is a good point.
>> [LAUGH]
>> All right, that sounds like a quiz.
>> Okay.